my father challenged me to subscribe to
leadership because my father wanted to
be a leader and everything that he ever
touched everybody who knows my father
he's a leader and I want it to be a
leaders what I wanted to be I wanted to
leave because in my life I haven't seen
something more rewarding than being
considered a leader somebody said well
how about being a parent having a kid is
more rewarding know being a parent that
leads your kid is rewarding because
you're a leader that's what's reporting
rewarding anybody can go make a baby
almost anybody can but leading that
family is what's rewarding so so what is
the basic 50% rule of leadership it's
very simple for me here's what it is
almost every one of us wants to be
pleasing everybody and have everybody
like us but that's not what leaders can
ever do anybody can ever do that if a
hundred percent of the world likes you
you're not a leader you're probably a
newborn baby because it's impossible to
have a hundred percent of people like
you but there are a lot of adults that
have most people like them because
they're afraid to rub people the wrong
way if a hundred percent of people don't
like you you're a jerk so you're either
a person that's wanting to please
everybody or you're simply a jerk you're
not good with people no one likes you
they just tolerate you right a leader
whether you're in Rand who writes a book
Atlas Shrugged 50% cannot stand at 50%
loves it if you're chris matthews if
you're Tip O'Neill or you're Ronald
Reagan you know most people don't like
you some people do like if you're
Michael Jordan it doesn't matter who you
are the leader is generally around the
50 percent number 50 percent will like
you 50 percent will not like you you're
a leader
so a Michael Jordan who came to the
Bulls and all of a sudden one year they
draft Horace Grant and Scottie Pippen
who are coming up as rookies and this
guy wants to win a championship they're
just glad to be in the NBA they're
partying and he's pushing them he's
kicking their butt they're not liking
them they're partying together Horace
and Scottie always talking behind his
back but there was one person who
completely understood what this guy was
doing and I was Phil Jackson because
Phil understood the only leader on his
team is a guy named Michael Jordan phil
pushed everybody
so eventually Scottie figured it out
because he wanted to win a championship
so that's
Scottie's subscribe fill subscribe the
ownership subscribe then Horace
subscribe then they want championships
but still half of the team the new
players that were coming Toni Kukoc you
know winning ten all these other guys
that were coming they don't like Jordan
cuz jordan drove everybody so you'll
generally know who the leaders are in
any organization because if in an
organization somebody make a list of
people in any organization say this
person everybody likes in a company
believe it or not that person is not a
leader that person somebody that wants
everybody to be pleased for other
reasons any say this person half the
group Robson half the group doesn't like
them that's the leader of the group
because they challenge everybody to
improve and you need to make a decision
yourself whether you want to be a leader
or you want to be a people pleaser or
you want to be a jerk it doesn't matter
the choice is yours but leadership 50%
rule is what you'll be dealing with for
the rest of your life